hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live
Angriffe auf Rathäuser brennende Autos
und Plünderung die Gewalt in Frankreich
die hört nicht auf vor knapp einer Woche
war der 17-Jährige nael in nortère das
ist ein Vorort von Frankreich von einem
Polizisten erschossen worden und seitdem
entlädt sich die Wut die Wut über diese
Tat die Wut über Polizeigewalt und
Diskriminierung auf den Straßen des
Landes nun also schon mehrere Tage in
Folge diese Szenen aus der Nacht der
Start der reagiert mit einer massiven
Polizeipräsenz auch jetzt waren wieder
45.000 Beamte und Beamte im Einsatz
viele Menschen mit Migrationshintergrund
die werfen den Behörden vor dass Sie sie
regelmäßig diskriminieren erheben
höchste Kritik an der Polizei Gewalt und
das ist ein Problem dass es nicht nur in
Frankreich gibt deshalb ist das heute
auch bei uns Thema Eskalation der Wut in
Frankreich das ist heute unser Thema ist
das auch in Deutschland möglich es gibt
von
die FDP von seitens des Generalsekretärs
eine Warnung die er in der Bild-Zeitung
geäußert hat er sagte das Defizite in
der Integrationspolitik eine Bedrohung
für die innere Sicherheit hier in
Deutschland sein wir wollen also darüber
sprechen mit euch und ihr könnt Fragen
stellen dazu mitdiskutieren im Stream
oder per Mail und wir haben uns zwei
Gäste dazu eingeladen jetzt am Anfang
ist bei mir Dr Emilia Rock sie ist
Politologin und Autorin geboren und
aufgewachsen in Frankreich und lebt in
Deutschland wir erreichen Sie jetzt in
Berlin und sie ist uns zugeschaltet
hallo schönen guten Abend Frau Dr roack
guten Abend
ich habe gerade schon zusammengefasst
und zwar diese Angriffe auf die Beamtin
und Beamte jetzt kam auch dazu ein
Brandanschlag auf das Haus eines
Bürgermeisters in Frankreich im etliche
Menschen jetzt aktuell in den Nächten
auf den Straßen in Frankreich die auch
auf Gewalt und Zerstörung aus sind wo
liegt da ihrer Meinung nach die Ursache
in diesem Ereignissen der letzten Tage
also die Ursache ist ganz klar es geht
um
Jahrzehnte der Ungerechtigkeit der
sozialen Ungerechtigkeit in Frankreich
es geht auch um die koloniale
Vergangenheit die koloniale Gegenwart
auch teilweise von Frankreich die nicht
verarbeitet wurde es gibt in Frankreich
noch sehr viele Ungerechtigkeiten auch
sozialer Ebene auf wirtschaftlicher
Ebene auf politischer Ebene und das
führt dazu dass große Teile der
französischen Bevölkerung
ungehört bleiben dass diese Menschen
marginalisiert werden dass sie in der
Gesellschaft wenig Platz auch finden und
wenn ihre Stimme nur so gehört werden
kann also wie Martin Luther King sagt
the rails ist der language of the
unhörde also das heißt die kravan ist
die Sprache der unerhörten na dann führt
es natürlich zu einer solchen einer
solchen Gewalt und nicht zuletzt ist
jetzt der Auflöser der Macht der Mord an
dem sie zehnjährigen in die Hand und
deshalb
ja ist es sehr
eskaliert jetzt in den letzten Tagen wir
sehen das ist nicht das erste Mal ist in
zweiter sind fünf gab es schon auch eine
große Welle ein ähnlicher Gewalt und
ähnliche Widerstand für dich da sondern
sie haben es selbst gerade angesprochen
genau 2005 gab es schon mal ähnlich
heftige Ausschreitungen aber was ist
dieses mal anders
ich glaube dieses Mal ist vor allem die
Tatsache dass
dass es nicht so viel passiert ist in
letzter Zeit das heißt das in den
letzten 20 Jahren in Frankreich und
jetzt sagen wir nur 15 Jahren ist mit
Bezug auf Polizei Gewalt mit Bezug auf
Marginalisierung von nicht weißen
Menschen in Frankreich nicht viel
passiert und ich glaube diese Gewalt hat
sich verschärft aber wenn wir jetzt von
Gewalt sprechen ich glaube dass sie sehr
wichtig auch zu differenzieren zwischen
also wo wovon sprechen wir diese Gewalt
die ist jetzt sehr sichtbar das heißt es
gibt
Gegenstände die brennen es gibt wirklich
Gewalt die sichtbar ist die auch
klar zu erkennen ist und auch woher
diese Gewalt auch stammt auch verletzte
beantinnen und Beamten ja entschuldigung
wenn ich das kurz anfügen darf also auch
verletzt ja ja absolut verletzte
Menschen also es ist wirklich eine
Gewalt die die auch
so ganz anders geworden ist und deshalb
finde ich das sehr schwierig auch über
wenn wir nicht über die Polizei Gewalt
sprechen also wenn wir nicht über die
staatliche Gewalt die auch unsichtbar
bleibt die meistens auch
nicht als Gewalt auf wahrgenommen wird
oder nicht als Gewalt auch beschrieben
wird genau ja
genau lassen Sie uns über diese
Polizeigewalt sprechen also Auslöser
zumindest dieser Funke der das jetzt
ausgelöst hat in dieser Heftigkeit war
eben jetzt der tödliche Schuss auf einer
l das war ein Schuss aus nächster Nähe
bei einer Polizeikontrolle wir sehen
auch Bilder jetzt dazu bei einer
Kontrolle eben wo Neil dann plötzlich
beschleunigte und dann dieser Schuss
durch seine Brust dann ein tödlicher
Schuss war der aus nächster Nähe
abgefeuert wurde wie groß ist dieses
Problem der Polizei Gewalt in Frankreich
insbesondere gegenüber Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund
die Gewalt gegen Menschen mit
Migrationshintergrund die Gewalt
gegenüber nicht weißen Menschen also es
geht wirklich um rassistische Gewalt es
muss auch benannt werden es ist ein
Problem dass auch mit ratio Profiling
auch zu tun hat
Organisationen wie anders sehen
international wie human right Swatch
haben auch lange darüber gesprochen es
gab mehrere Berichte Forschungen und
Studien die da auch sehr klar waren dass
Frankreich ein Problem hat also das
wurde auch auf unebene auch besprochen
und trotzdem wird es nicht ernst
genommen es wird immer wieder bei der
teleisiert und für harmlos diese Gewalt
ist aber eine ein großes Problem und das
muss ja es muss aufhören und da sehen
wir heute dass dass die reden jetzt
nicht über einen Einzelfall dass dies
kein Einzelfall es wiederholt sich auch
immer wieder und in Deutschland ist das
Problem auch nicht ähm also das ist auch
ein Problem dass Deutschland hat und
auch andere europäische Länder also wenn
wir über Belgien sprechen z.B oder über
UK also das sind Probleme auf ganz
europäische oder wenigstens so hier auf
dem erweiterten Kontinent
der 17-Jährige generell der wuchs in
einem Vorort von Paris in einem
sogenannten bonjo auf und was es
bedeutet wenn das der Staat ins Leben
ist dazu schauen wir uns gemeinsam einen
Beitrag an von Axel Konrad
günstiger Wohnraum für
Geringqualifizierte und Geringverdiener
dafür wurden in Frankreich schon in den
50er Jahren in den Großstädten riesige
Hochhaussiedlungen gebaut mal wie hier
in Marseille mitten in der Stadt meist
aber außerhalb der Zentren sowie in
Paris
5,2 Millionen Menschen leben heute in
solchen Vierteln überwiegend Einwanderer
schon früh wurden die Quartiere zu
Sammelbecken für die sozial abgehängten
und so sind sie auch zum Sinnbild für
eine misslungen der Integration geworden
wer hier aufwächst hat deutlich
schlechtere Chancen als im Rest der
Republik das belegen diese Zahlen
die Arbeitslosenquote ist mehr als
doppelt so hoch bei den Männern 2022
19,6% gegenüber 8,8 im
Landesdurchschnitt die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit liegt in vielen
der Problemvierteln da jenseits der 40
Prozent und die armutquote 2020 lag sie
bei mehr als 42 Prozent gegenüber 17
landesweit der bildungsdurchschnitt ist
schlechter mehr als die Hälfte der
Jugendlichen hat gerade mal den
niedrigsten Abschluss
in den vergangenen Jahren gab es immer
wieder Unruhen in diesen Vierteln oft
nach Fällen von Polizei Gewalt der
Unterschied heute die Jugendlichen sind
deutlich jünger oft Kinder sie agieren
in kleineren Gruppen und stimmen sich
über soziale Netzwerke ab
ist das für sie so ein großer Teil des
Problems Frau Dr Rock dass da ein Raum
geschaffen wurde wo Menschen mit
geringem Einkommen oftmals eben auch mit
einer nicht weißen Hautfarbe
hinabgeschoben werden
ja definitiv also die Infrastruktur und
diese ja Stadtentwicklung Politik aber
das war überhaupt keine Politik dann
also das wurde eine Politik die aber
nicht durch Start war weil ursprünglich
war das ähm die Idee dass die Menschen
die jetzt nach Frankreich kommen um zu
arbeiten also die Gastarbeiter Zeit dass
sie dann irgendwann zurückkehren sollten
also mit einer
steigender Bevölkerung in nicht weiß er
Herkunft hier in Frankreich haben sie
damit nicht gerechnet und das ist
Hauptprobleme glaube ich dass diese Orte
sind Orte die ohne Zukunft Ausblick also
das sind Orte der Marginalisierung wie
ich gesagt habe und es ist dann sehr
problematisch weil auch die Entfernung
von Hauptstädten erschwert diese
Integration
ja und dann natürlich wenn die Polizei
Gewalt auch konzentriert auf diesen
Bereichen konzentriert auf diesen
biografischen Zonen und da auch die das
Schulsystem z.B unterfinanziert ist ist
und die Probleme in diesen Gebieten gar
nicht auffangen kann dann für das
natürlich zu einer sozialen Situation
die nicht mehr zu kontrollieren ist es
sind besonders junge Menschen das haben
wir auch im Beitrag gehört sehr junge
Menschen die da jetzt aktuell auf der
Straße sind französische Politikerinnen
und Politiker die sagen im Vergleich
auch zu den Ausschreitungen davor sein
dass eben wirklich noch mal deutlich
jüngere Menschen die können sie sich das
erklären warum das jetzt noch mal jünger
geworden ist
ich glaube es gibt eine eine
Verschränkung von unterschiedlichen
Krisen und jüngere die jüngere
Bevölkerung ist da besonders betroffen
also die Klimakrise ist allgegenwärtig
das heißt es gibt glaube ich in den
jüngeren Generationen auch ein Gefühl
von Hilflosigkeit eine Gefühl von
Orientierungslosigkeit und die Wut ist
da auch spürbarer ich kann mir das aber
erklären weil
in den Jüngern Generationen oder ich
würde sagen dass da sind die
Generationen auch die jetzt in letzter
Zeit dass sie die 2005 auch teilweise
schon da waren und das auch alles
mitbekommen haben
und auf die sozialen Medien gibt es auch
mehr Sichtbarkeit für diese Themen es
gibt mehr Möglichkeiten auch für die
Vernetzung Menschen können auch diese
kollektive Wut irgendwie auch besser
ausleben als in den fördergeneration das
einzige Problem ist dass die einzige
Möglichkeit die es gibt im Moment um
diesen stimmen dass die dass sie gehört
werden ist eine solche Gewalt und diese
Eskalation
richtet sich natürlich nicht einen
richtigen Menschen ich sehe da aber auch
trotzdem ein Problem wenn wir nur die
Mittel oder die Strategien die da
angewendet werden kritisieren und nicht
die Ursachen des Problems auch ernst
nehmen weil es ist jetzt ein
Ausdrucksmittel das ist jetzt nicht
freie Gewalt es ist jetzt keine Gewalt
die einfach
sie machen das nicht aus Spaß und ich
glaube sehr oft auch wird immer wieder
die Gewalt in Verbindung gebracht mit
diesen Bevölkerungsgruppen als etwas das
immer nennt ist oder das etwas das
intrin sich ist an diesem
Bevölkerungsgruppen also das heißt
rassistische narrativen die da auch
mobilisiert werden um diese Gewalt zu
erklären und da glaube ich sind solche
Verkürzungen sehr gefährlich es gibt
aber auch Stimmen die dagegen sagen dass
jetzt von diesen vielen vielen Menschen
die da auf der Straße sind eben auch
einige darunter sind ohne politische
politische Forderungen und einfach nur
da unterwegs sind um Gewalt der Gewalt
wegen anzuwenden was würden sie dem
entgegnen
an dem Moment wo Menschen
unter diesen Bedingungen leben und
systematisch
strukturell
institutionell ausgegrenzt sind Menschen
also ganze Bevölkerungsgruppen die vom
Staat auch ja in ausgegrenzt werden dann
kann man nicht sagen dass sie nicht
politisiert sind es kann sein dass sie
diese politischen auf Anforderungen
nicht klar artikulieren aber diese Wut
muss auch ernst genommen werden und
deshalb finde ich das interessant dass
zum Beispiel die Wut von hier in
Deutschland AFD Villa oder die Menschen
die also proteststelle von z.B ähm
rechtspopulistischen Parteien überall in
Europa ernst genommen werden und es wird
den Menschen auch nicht unterstellt dass
sie zum Beispiel jetzt keine
Politisierung auch in der haben sondern
einfach nur rassistische Motive und
deshalb finde ich das wichtig diese
diese diese diese Doppel morale oder
dieser zweier Lamas auch zu hinterfragen
kommen wir auch zu der Frage ob das eben
auch eine Gefahr für uns jetzt in
Deutschland sein könnte solche Zustände
oder solche Eskalation wir schauen uns
vorher einen Beitrag gemeinsam an Zahlen
und Fakten von Julia Schröter
Europa Ziel viele Einwanderer
2021 kamen 439.000 Migranten aus nicht
EU-Ländern in Deutschland an deutlich
mehr als in Frankreich da waren es
248000 Menschen
ähnlich verschieden das Bild beim Thema
Migrationshintergrund in Deutschland
haben nach aktuellen Zahlen
28,7% der Bevölkerung einen
Migrationshintergrund das heißt
mindestens ein Elternteil hat nicht von
Geburt an die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft in Frankreich sind es
mindestens 21% der Bevölkerung
Problemthema Jugendarbeitslosigkeit sie
ist in Deutschland im Vergleich niedrig
6,1%. in Frankreich liegt sie bei
16,9%. etwas darunter der Durchschnitt
der Eurozone da sind es 13,9%
. wir haben es gerade gehört weniger
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit bei uns aber mehr
eingewanderte Menschen die sicher auch
Staat Hilfe beim Staat in Deutschland
brauchen wie sieht das ihrer Meinung
nach aus wie hoch ist das Potenzial für
eine Eskalation wie in Frankreich wenn
Integration bei uns eben nicht
funktioniert
also nochmal die Gewalt ist in
Deutschland auch schon mal
allgegenwärtig also das ist auch die
Frage so für wen ist es jetzt eine
Bedrohung und wer ist jetzt gerade auch
bedroht also ich würde sagen mit dem
reisenenden rechtsextremistischen
Parteien und Ansichten und Gruppierungen
hier in Deutschland sind große
Bevölkerungsteilen auch gefährdet sie
sind bedroht und das ist auch eine akute
Gefahr die aber weniger ernst genommen
wird jetzt klar es gibt in Deutschland
auch das Problem Polizei Gewalt es gibt
auch das Problem also Arbeitslosigkeit
und Marginalisierung da sind tatsächlich
auch gesellschaftliche Probleme hier in
Deutschland ich würde sagen es gibt auch
ein Unterschied und das ist die Tatsache
dass er sich hier in Deutschland nicht
ähm reicht auf deutschen Boden auch
geboren zu sein oder hier lange genug
gelebt zu haben es gibt viele Menschen
die hier die Staatsangehörigkeit nicht
haben und deshalb auch in einer sehr
prekären Situationen sind mit Bezug auf
Aufenthaltsrecht
sagt Dr Emilia Rock vielen Dank dass Sie
bei uns zu Gast waren wir vertiefen
jetzt das Thema noch hier wie es um die
Situation in Deutschland bestellt das
Sagen und vielen Dank an Frau Dr Rock
und zwar haben wir uns jetzt noch einen
Gast eingeladen und bei uns ist jetzt
der Professor Dr Andreas Zick er leitet
das Institut für interdisziplinäre
Konflikt und gewaltforschung an der
Universität Universität Bielefeld schön
dass Sie bei uns sind hallo guten Abend
hallo
sie haben eben gerade auch mit zugehört
was frau dr Rock uns geschildert hat wie
sehen Sie das Konfliktpotenzial bei uns
das Gewaltpotenzial bei uns Frau Dr Rock
hat darauf hingewiesen dass natürlich
viele Menschen hier auch in einem
prekären Aufenthaltsstatus leben dass
man sich auch anschauen müsste natürlich
wer hier wie bedroht ist wie schätzen
Sie die Situation hier in Deutschland
ein
also das was wir in Frankreich sehen ist
für uns ein Warnsignal ich glaube wir
sollten genau hingucken und sollten
jetzt nicht überlegen gibt's da
Parallelen und ist das jetzt hier alles
auch so entzündbar aber tatsächlich die
Probleme die in Frankreich zu dem Unmut
geführt haben die haben wir in
teilnehmen auch hier auch hier haben
Jugendliche junge Menschen erlebt über
die corona-zeit dass Sie Ihre
Bedürfnisse Interessen nicht hinreichend
beachtet wurden auch hier sehen wir in
den Studien eigentlich längere Zeit Frau
reuk hat ja darauf hingewiesen eine
höhere Gewaltbereitschaft insbesondere
in radikal ideologisch motivierten
Milieus insbesondere im
Rechtsextremismus wir haben auch da eine
junge Gewalt die ist auch angestiegen da
werden Räume besetzt allerdings das was
in Frankreich dort passiert in der
Breite in den Städten was dort sich
organisiert da würde ich da verwandt zu
schnell Parallelen zu ziehen wir haben
ja auch hier solche polizeige
klappt auch Tötungsdelikte wir hatten
die die das Tötungsdelikt in der
Nordstadt am 8 August 2022 in der
Dortmunder Nordstadt hat ein Polizist
mit dem steuerfeuerwaffe ein
Jugendlichen getötet und wir hatten auch
black lives matter Bewegung als George
Floyd ermordet wurde in den USA im Mai
2020 auch da haben wir Proteste gesehen
junge Proteste hier in Deutschland auf
der Straße aber das ist Zivil abgelaufen
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir uns mit der
Frage auch beschäftigen wie steht es um
unsere Jugend es wird sicherlich werden
sich Teile der Jugend auch das angucken
was in Frankreich ist aber wir haben
hier noch viel stärker eine
zivilgesellschaftliche orientierte
Gesellschaft wir arbeiten in Deutschland
auch das Thema Polizeigewalt jetzt
besser auf als es früher der Fall war
und insofern schnelle Parallelen zu
ziehen da würde ich doch vor Wagen
nichtsdestotrotz müssen wir uns mit dem
Thema Gewalt wie Frau Wolk das gesagt
hat intensiv beschäftigen denn wir
übersehen viele ideologisch motivierte
Gewalt insbesondere im Bereich des
Rechtsextremismus lassen sie uns da
gerne gleich noch weiter darauf eingehen
ich möchte auch die User gerne mit
einbinden es gibt Kommentare zu schreibt
der User die Userin Dux bei Youtube sie
oder er glaubt nicht dass es in dem
Umfang möglich ist hier bei uns in
Deutschland Frankreich hat ein ganz hat
eine ganz andere Migrationspolitik sowie
Vergangenheit und einen anderen Aufbau
von Stadt und Land leider meint hier
aber Marc Steuer bei Youtube sei das
nicht sehr unwahrscheinlich ihr solche
Zustände auch bei uns auf den Straßen
absolut möglich findet der oder die
Userin Benjo sakuza und wir haben hier
auch eine Frage im Stream die ich gerne
noch an Sie stellen möchte und zwar
schreibt ein User der oder die sich
Potential politics nennt sollte man
nicht dazu sagen dass das französische
Politiksystem anders ist und die
Menschen protestieren müssen weil der
Präsident viel mehr Befugnisse hat wie
also anders als hier der Bundeskanzler
wie sehen Sie das ja ich glaube dass wir
in Frankreich ein Bündel haben ein
Bündel an Faktoren die das ermöglichen
da gibt es zum einen die soziökonomische
Lage die Spaltung ist sehr groß wir
haben das auch aber nicht in dem Maße
und Sie haben ja auch einige der Fakten
genannt dann haben wir eine geografische
Spaltung Paris die großen Städte wären
werden wahrgenommen als
gespalten in der Republik das läuft
alles über Paris und eine starke Sport
Staatsmacht wir haben eine politische
Ebene wir haben bei den Wahlen auch bei
den Präsidentschaftswahlen gesehen junge
Menschen entscheiden sich dann
wenn die 18 bis 25 sind für für linke
radikale Kräfte wir sehen aber auch dann
in den älteren
Altersspanne eine eine Präferenz für
leben die Marine leben also in den
Frauen national das heißt hier hat
wirklich auch schon eine Radikalität
jetzt aus die wir vorher gesehen gesehen
haben und dann haben wir eine starke
Spaltung zwischen den Eliten in
Frankreich und den jungen Menschen wir
haben in Frankreich viele junge Menschen
die einen akademischen Abschluss haben
und trotzdem keine Perspektive haben wir
sehen die Spaltung in den Städten wir
haben die bandiös an den Renten das sind
der Protest kann sich sehr viel stärker
auch geographisch über den Raum bilden
wir müssen ja erklären wie an so vielen
Stellen ist so breit in der Gesellschaft
dann auf einmal Proteste gibt in seiner
Hochgeschwindigkeit und Frau Reuter
darauf hingewiesen da muss eine
gemeinsame Identität hergestellt werden
die diesen protestmöglich macht und
diese politische Identität einem
missachteten Jugend die unter vielen
sozialen Repressionen leidet und auch
ein sehr gespaltenes Verhältnis hat zur
Polizei und auch zum Staat das hat sich
über Jahre entwickelt und dieses
Faktoren gemischt und diese
identitätsbildenden Prozesse wie sehen
wir in Deutschland nicht und dann haben
wir natürlich die soziale Ebene viele
Proteste in Frankreich berufen sich
jetzt auf Missachtung Jugend ist
missachtet worden und da hoffen wir dass
wir in Deutschland in dem föderalen
System solche massiven Formen einer
nationalen Missachtung in solcher
Bewegungsform nicht haben
da wir hatten ja auch in Deutschland
Proteste während der corona-pandemie die
blieben aber lokal und die konnten
befriedet werden weil wir auch starke
zivilgesellschaftliche Kräfte haben die
dann eine Stimme geben für die
missachteten Gruppen und das ist in
Frankreich nicht der Fall und Frankreich
ist ein Land in dem die Spaltung
zwischen politischen Eliten mit ihrem
repressionssystem über Polizei und so
weiter als sehr stark Distanz
wahrgenommen wird jetzt gibt es Stimmen
wie die das FDP Generalsekretärs der
sich geäußert hat ich habe es am Anfang
der Sendung angesprochen in der
Bild-Zeitung gewarnt hat davon
gesprochen hat dass Defizite in der
Integrationspolitik hier in Deutschland
eine Bedrohung für die innere Sicherheit
sein sprach außerdem in seiner Warnung
eben vor den Zuständen wie in Frankreich
vor einer unkontrollierten Zuwanderung
vor der er warnt hier in Deutschland was
würden Sie ihm entgegnen wenn er sich so
äußert als ich glaube wir müssen uns
damit beschäftigen in Frankreich das
sind jugendproteste und das sind
Proteste gegen soziale Verhältnisse dass
da natürlich jetzt auch Blinde rein und
all das dabei sind und dass es dort
welche gibt die aus der Gewalt Gewinne
ziehen alles das wird hoffentlich in
Frankreich aufgearbeitet aber wir haben
in Deutschland den Mechanismus schnell
aufzuarbeiten und ich würde jetzt nicht
versuchen politisch dort andere Themen
draufzusetzen wir haben Silvester
diskutiert über die Gewalt über die
Gewalt von migrantischen Communitys in
Berlin wenn wir uns daran erinnern und
wenn die genauen Analysen wenn wir die
Fakten jetzt heranziehen dann der
zaubert sich das das sind heterogene
Gruppen wir müssen uns beschäftigen mit
der Frage wie geht es Jugend und wie
politisch orientiert es Jugend und hat
sie genügend eine Stimme und nicht ein
Thema wie Migration darüber legen
natürlich können wir jede Form von
Migrationsdebatte führen aber in
Deutschland hätten wir schon früher
migrantische Gewalt gesehen wenn sich
wenn sich diese Gewalt wie die jetzt in
Frankreich ja auch in die Breite geht
das sind vor allen Dingen Minderjährige
die dort mitmachen und das sind
heterogene Gruppen das ist eine Form von
jugendprotest die sich in Gewalt äußert
und da in diesem Rahmen sollten wir
bleiben und nicht vor schnell versuchen
jetzt wieder das Thema der
Migrationskarte zu führen bei den
Silvester Gewalt haben wir gesehen es
waren migrantische Communitys die genau
eingeschritten sind und versucht haben
das ganze einzugrenzen die versuchen
jetzt auch eine gewisse bessere
Gewaltprävention hinzubekommen
also ich wäre vorsichtig davor jetzt so
ein Bedrohungsszenario aufzubauen als
wenn sich hier eine migrantische Gruppen
formieren würden wir haben auch Gewalt
gesehen darüber müssen wir auch reden im
Ruhrgebiet in den letzten Wochenenden an
vielen anderen Städten das sind zaubert
sich als Clan Gewalt als
familiärorientierte Gewalt damit müssen
wir uns beschäftigen aber die Lage ist
anders ich glaube Frankreich sollte uns
eher dazu führen dass wir noch mal
gucken wie geht es eigentlich den jungen
Menschen was haben sie erlebt in wir
haben Krisen die junge Menschen viel
stärker treffen soziale Ungleichheit
Perspektivlosigkeit Hoffnungslosigkeit
das sind die Themen und da wäre ich sehr
vorsichtig so ein generalfaktor wieder
hier zu suchen ich glaube diese Debatte
brauchen wir nicht junge Menschen
erleben eine Missachtung
viele sagen wenn wir hier leben wenn wir
hier kommen und wenn wir uns einsetzen
für dieses Land und hier mit
Zivilgesellschaft tragen dann kommt
immer wieder eine migrationsdiskussion
das wird erlebt als Missachtung und ich
werde politisch sehr vorsichtig da
schnell die Faktoren zu vermengen
sondern lieber eine solide Analyse
dessen was passiert in Frankreich und
wie geht's unserer Jugend und ähm wie
gehen wir damit um dass wir ja schon
Teile von Jugend Gewalt gesehen im z.B
im Bereich des Rechtsextremismus was wir
dann oft nicht genau als Jugendgewalt
bestimmen obwohl wir wissen dass gerade
die hasstaten in diesem Bereich
insbesondere in bestimmten Räumen von
jungen Menschen verliebt werden wir
müssen in die sozialen Räume hinein
gucken und gucken gibt's da Schieflagen
aber eine große politische Organisation
der politisch motivierten migrantischen
Gewalt
das das diese Diskussion glaube ich
brauchen wir nicht zu führen weil wir
dafür keine Fakten haben
Zustimmung von Userin Polinen die
schreibt die Jugend wird eh immer gerne
übersehen dann aber die Frage
entschuldigung aber sie wird eben auch
in Haft genommen unser Jugendbild unser
Jugendbild ist auch dass wir eine sehr
sehr strafrechtsorientierte Einstellung
zu Jugend haben wir müssen uns damit
beschäftigen wie Jugend aufwachsen kann
in diesen Zeiten von Krisen und
Frankreich erzählt ja die Geschichte
viele Jugendliche üben jetzt Gewalt aus
weil sie weil die Gewalt die Ultima Rat
so ist weil das ist das letzte Mittel
ist und weil sie sich radikalisiert
haben in diese Idee der absoluten
Hoffnungslosigkeit und jetzt in der
Gewalt Gewinne sehen das wird ja alles
wieder abflauen und das wird auch
eingegangen eingegrenzt aber wir sehen
in Frankreich auch dass eine reine
strafrechtsorientierte Politik Polizei
bewaffnen in die Band das hinein zu
gehen wir haben früher mal das Bild
gehabt das durch Kärcher ins hat Herr
sacrossin mal gesagt in den beiden lös
dass diese reine strafrechtsorientierung
diese Verdächtigung uns nicht weiter
bringt sondern wir müssen uns
beschäftigen wie es Jugend geht und wenn
wir sehen in Frankreich sind auch viele
Jugendliche abgerutscht in die
nichtwählerinnen und nicht wie in der
Milieus und solche Phänomene haben wir
auch und das sind alles Prozesse die aus
einer Hoffnungslosigkeit heraus
resultieren und wir leben in Zeiten von
vielen vielen Krisen junge Menschen
erleben das und ähm damit müssen wir uns
viel eher beschäftigen das sollte er
anders sein dann ganz zum Schluss eben
noch die Frage an Sie von dem User der
Userin rexus also was kann man tun eben
hier in Deutschland um solche Situation
so eine Situation überhaupt es zu
vermeiden mehr Jugendarbeit das habe ich
verstanden was würden Sie gerne noch
anfügen
tatsächlich ist es so dass wir im
Bereich der Jugendarbeit der Sozialen
Arbeit
sehr viel sehr viel mehr machen müssen
dass wir Themen auch wie Erziehung noch
mal genau uns angucken müssen was meinen
wir eigentlich damit die Jugend äußert
sich hier mit Gewalt politisch scheinbar
politisch in Frankreich das kann ich
sein also es braucht auch eben immer
wieder politische Bildung
demokratiebildung
migrantische Communitys wenn wir sollten
wir nicht Verdächtigen sondern sie
stärken darin eben Zivilgesellschaft
sich zu engagieren und Gewaltprävention
vor Ort und sicherlich auch andere
Konzepte Frankreich zeigt uns dass das
reine Vorgehen der Polizei das reingehen
in solche Gruppen und das reine
Strafverfolgung und das reine
Durchsetzen von Rechten nicht hilft in
Deutschland haben wir gute Erfahrungen
gemacht mit Jugend Kontaktbeamten und
Beamten also im Bereich der Gewalt
Situation das ist wichtig und ich glaube
Frankreich sollte uns Anlass geben noch
mal darüber nachzudenken wo ist unsere
Jugend und können wir der Jugend
hinreichend Perspektive geben die Gewalt
ist die eine weg aber nicht wählen zu
gehen sich nicht an Demokratie zu
beteiligen oder wie in vielen Bereichen
dann in rechtsextreme Szenen
abzurutschen oder im islamistisches
sehen wie das auch hatten
da müssen wir immer wieder vorsichtig
sein die Zeiten sind voller Krisen und
es trifft eben bestimmte Gruppen vor
allen Dingen junge Menschen sagt
Professor Dr Andreas Zick von der
Universität Universität Bielefeld vielen
Dank dass Sie uns zu Gast waren danke
Ihnen
und wir können mitnehmen dass es darum
geht auf die Jugend zu schauen sich zu
fragen wie ist der Jugend geht vielen
Dank dass ihr so lange jetzt dran
geblieben seid so viele Fragen und
Kommentare geschrieben hat ich hoffe ich
habe einige davon hier beantworten
können bzw unsere Gäste haben die
beantworten können für heute erstmal
vielen Dank gerne beim nächsten Mal
wieder tschüss